foreign
hey everyone and welcome to another hd
tutorial and in this video today i'll be
going over how to enable advanced um and
uh more
basically more optimized computer
performance based on an external hard
drive or a hard disk that you have
so right now i've plugged into my usb
hub a little usb drive and we want to
speed this up and enable it for
optimized performance because we're not
going to be removing a whole lot this
also works if you have say an external
hard drive or something so what we're
going to do is just click on the start
button and this works in xp or vista
right click on my computer
and hit the manage button and if uac
does pop up allow anything that uic asks
for so just say continue or allow or
anything whatever it asks
so this is a computer management window
this is how you manage everything we're
going to go to device manager it's going
to be under the system tools one
and then we're going to go over here on
the right hand side and expand disk
drives we're not going to click on it
just expand it and here you'll see this
is my external hard drive my 7200 rpm
250 gig x internal hard drive and my
x101 is unplugged right now and here's
the usb flash memory device that i have
plugged in with storage on it if i want
to enable advanced hard drive
performance simply right click and go to
properties
this usb flash memory properties and
devices window comes up hit the policies
tab and here you'll see optimize for
quick removal or for performance if you
optimize it for quick removal it's it's
disabling caching on the disk so
information is not readable readily
available in your cache or your cache
whatever you want to call it but if you
optimize it for for performance here it
enables disk writing to the windows
cache to our cache to improve disk
performance so i'm just going to hit ok
and if it does ask for a restart you
would hit yes and i recommend restarting
it as soon as you make these changes but
i'm going to hit no for the purpose of
finishing this video but that's
basically it so you can right click hit
properties and advanced performance now
obviously this is my internal hard drive
so i have checked the enable advanced
performance icon now if you are running
on a laptop you don't want to have your
internal hard drive
on advanced performance unless you're
running on a battery because if you do
lose battery or power for some reason
that would be really bad you might
actually lose data or completely have an
unusable drive but that is how to enable
advanced disk performance on your uh
your windows machine i hope this
tutorial was helpful if you do have any
other tutorial ideas or requests for me
go ahead and subscribe and i will get to
them as soon as i can so thanks for
watching this video and stay tuned for
more peace